so as a dietitian how do you like to  make your eggs anyway all the ways but  if I had to pick a single way to do eggs  this is what I do most often  off three Rich eggs my little hack is I  add in a little bit of cottage cheese  cottage cheese is like packed with  protein there's 14 grams of protein and  a half cup so it's a great way to just  like bulk up the protein even more  a little salt a little pepper  and we gotta obviously double down on  the cheese Factor so that they've got  lots of really yummy cheesy flavor Brody  are you ketchup are you hot sauce  definitely hot sauce but I do love  ketchup as well well I got this like  Curry ketchup so it's like spicy and  it's like a ketchup kind of Base it is  next level good so that's what we're  using today cannot wait to dive in what  do you mean  oh yeah